[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
العسكريه التركيه في سوريا والعراق وموسكو
تدعو انقره الى ضبط النفس
ايران تستخدمه اجهزه طرد المركزي متطوره
في مفعل فوده وتسعه لتخصيب اليورانيوم
بنسبه 60%
وزير الدفاع الصيني واكيد لنظيره
الامريكيه ضروره احترام مصالح بلاده ويجدد
ان تايوان خط احمر
ونائبه الرئيس الامريكي تعلن دعمها
للفلبين في مواجهه السياسات العاديه ببحر
الصين الجنوبي
مشاهدينا اتفاق امريكي روسي نادر الحدوث
اتفاق البلدين جاء هذه المره ضد العمليات
العسكريه التي تستهدف الاكراد في شمال
سوريا وايضا العراق المبعوث الروسي الى
سوريا
اكد على اهميه البحث عن حل السلمي للقضيه
الكرديه كما دعا المبعوث الروسي تركيا الى
الامتناع عن استخدام القوه العسكريه
المفرطه في سوريا مشيرا الى ان موسكو
ستعمل مع الشركاء لايجاد حلل للصراع
الدائره هناك اما الولايات المتحده فجاء
موقفها على لسان المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه اند برايس والذي اكد
ان الولايات المتحده تعارض اي عمل العسكري
يزعزع استقرار الوضع في سوريا المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه اضاف ان واشنطن
ابلغت انقره بواس قلقها الشديده من تاثير
مثل هذا الهجوم على هذا في محاربه تنظيم
داعش برايس اكد ايضا ان الولايات المتحده
ما زالت تعارض اي عمل عسكري غير منسق في
العراق
ينتهكوا سيادته على كل ان للمزيد معنا من
موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
اهلا بك عبد الجواد اسمحلي ان ابدا بهذا
التوافق كيف يقرا الامريكي طبعا الروسي
حول روسيا تحديدا هل هو صدفه المصالح وجدت
هناك او لا الموضوع يختلف وهناك ربما نوع
من الغزل الامريكي الروسي الان
مرحبا
بما يخص العمليه العسكريه في الشمال
السوري وكردستان العراق الجميع يتحدث عن
وجود تقارب في وجهات النظر والتي طبعا
تدعو الى وقف الاعمال العسكريه وعدم
التعامل مع هذه طبعا العمليه بمواقف قاسيه
جدا لكن طبعا على الجانب الاخر ما زالت
موسكو وسياسي وهيتحدثون عن النقيض الكبير
والاختلاف الواضح بين الولايات المتحده
وروسيا بما يخص طبعا هذه العمليه في
الاراضي السوريه تبعا باعتبار ان موسكو
تدعم الحكومه السوريه وهي متواجده وحاضره
في العديد من النقاط على الاراضي الروسيه
موسكو كما تحدث سابقا لم تغير موقفها بما
يخص طبعا دفع الاكراد نحو
الغربي نوعا ما كانت نسميه موسكو والبحث
عن نقاط لايجاد حل الموقف تتوقف مع
الحكومه السوريه لكن طبعا حتى هذه اللحظه
نلاحظ باناموسكو وواشنطن قد تتحدث عن
تنسيق امني كبير داخل الاراضي السوريه
خاصه بما يخص قضيه الطائرات وقضيه الجو
والطيران
المقاتلاتنا
التصريحات الروسيه المتعلقه بالعراق كانت
نوعا ما خجوله
اليوم
الاستراتيجي شبه الاول تقريبا بما يخص
دعمها في العمليه العسكريه موسكو لم تتحدث
رسميا عن وصول اسلحه ايرانيه الى روسيا
لدعمها في الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكنها تجد
في ايران وفي طهران حنيفا يعني نادرا او
شبه نادر اليوم بما يخص قيادتها ومواجتها
لانها في العمليه العسكريه في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لذلك هي طبعا كما يرى الخبراء
والباحثون السياسيون هنا في البلاد بانها
شبه راضيه عما يحدث في شمال العراق هي
تؤيد من طرف لكن تدعوا ايضا الى العوده
الى الحوار وايجاد حل قضيه الاكرار في تلك
المناطق لكن طبعا حسب مع بعض القراءه
السياسيه في البلاد بان حكومه العراق
اليوم طبعا غير قاضيه غير قادره بشكل كلي
وبشكل كامل على احتواء هذا الموقف واحتواء
هذه
بالعراق ولكن في نوع من الحضور الثقيل في
سوريا موسكو تتحدث عن مساء يمكن ان تقوم
بها عن ماذا نتحدث هنا
الاطراف لجلوس الى طاوله واحده تبحث عن حل
لقضيه الاكراد في شمال سوريا وهي مختلفه
بشكل كبير عن قضيه كردستان العراق وفي
شمال العراق باعتبار انها في سوريا حتى
هذه اللحظه هي هي غير رسميه بشكل كبير
موسكو تبحث عن محاوله جمع همم الاكراد في
شمال سوريا مع اعضاء الحكومه السوريه
لايجاد حل هذا الموضوع طبعا هي ورقه همم
موجوده طبعا همم يمكن ان توصل لتقارب بين
الجانبين التركي السوري في هذا الموضوع
ايضا ما يصوم طبعا موسكو عسكريا هي قريبا
جدا من القضيه والموقف في شمال سوريا
باعتبار ان احميم والمرفق والقواعد
العسكريه التي اتخذت منها موسكو في تلك
المنطقه مكانا لها عسكريا هي قريبه جدا من
ساحه العمليه الان
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
طبعا مشاهدينا بغض النظر عن التلاقي
الامريكي الروسي في التصريحات حول هذا
القصف التركي انقر اكدت على لسان وزير
دفاعيا خلصي اكار اكدت ان العمليه
العسكريه في شمال سوريا والعراق هي الاجمل
والاكثر فعاليه ضد المسلحين هناك وزير
الدفاع التركي اكد ان قوات بلاده حيدت 188
شخصا وصفهم بالارهابيين منذ انطلاق عمليات
المخلب السيف طبعا بري وجوي شمال سوريا
وايضا العراق ما استمع
اليهود ثمن الوحشيه التي اطهروها في
الهجوم الاخير في منطقه اسطنبول سنجعلهم
يدفعون ثمن كل الجرائم التي ارتكبوها
اليوم وما قبلها وفقا لاخر المعلومات التي
تلقيناها وفي اعقاب غاراتنا الجويه
المدعومه باسلحه الارضيه تم تحديده 184
مسلحها
المزيد معنا من اسطنبول استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه الدكتور سمير صالحه اهلا بك دكتور
اسمح لي ان ابدا بقراءتك لهذه التصريحات
الامريكيه الروسيه المتوافقه نوعا ما في
ما يتعلق بالقصف التركي وبالمقابل كيف
لتركيا ان تتعامل معها
صحيح صباح الخير للجميع اولا طبعا من
الممكن ان يكون هناك حوار امريكي روسي
بشكل او باخر سواء كان في التعامل مع
الملف السوري او موضوع العراق ايضا لكن لا
اظن انه هذا الحوار
سيتحول الى تفهمات او تنسيق امريكي روسي
في مواجهه
العمليه العسكريه التركيه اظن العكس هو
صحيح كل البلدين اعلن يتفاهمه انه هذه
العمليه مرتبطه بعمل ارهابي تم في قلب
مدينه اسطنبول وبالامس ايضا كان في
استهداف اخر دي المدنيين في همم منطقه
غازي عنتاب الحدوديه هذا يعني انه الدكتور
صحيح في تفهم صحيح لما حدث داخل التركي
ولكن هذا لا يمنع انه في تنديد لان يخرج
الرد خارج الحدود التركيه
لسياده الدول بهذا الاطار دكتور
صحيح صحيح
حق الدفاع المشروع عن النفس ميثاق الامم
المتحده اذا كان في تهديد او استهداف من
قبل دوله مجاوره لدوله اخرى مجاوره فهي
عندها الحق بالرد الان الوضع في سوريا في
شمال سوريا الوضع في شمال العراق واضح
للجميع اذا هذه المجموعات الارهابيه هذه
التنظيمات تستفيد من هذه البقعه الجغرافيه
وتتحرك لاستهداف الداخل التركي اذن عمليه
الرد التركي مرتبطه بهذه الماده حسب
القانون الدولي لا اظن انه واشنطن موسكو
لا يعرف فان لماذا الان تتحرك همم تركيا
بهذا الاتجاه السؤال دكتور دكتور
تركيا تتحرك بثقل ولكن بالمقابل نحن نعلم
انه ليس الاستهداف الاول ان كان في العراق
او في سوريا
سيكون الاستهداف في العاشر
اذا ما بقيت هذه المجموعات الارهابيه
تستفيد من الاراضي من هذه الفوضى من هذه
الحاله في شمال سوريا في شمال العراق
الاستهداف الداخلي التركي يعني واشنطن
وموسكو اذا كان يريدان ان يقدمه هي ليست
باقناع تركيا بوقف عملياتها العسكريه بل
بالبحث عن صيغه تسويه حقيقيه لانهاء تواجد
هذه المجموعات في البقعتين الجغرافيتين
بالعكس واشنطن تستفيد من هذه الوضعيه
ومسكوا ايضا تستفيد والان في محاوله لرمي
الكره في ملعب الجانب التركي يعني من الذي
شجع هذه المجموعات غزاها مولاها وصلها الى
هذه النقطه التي تتحرك بهذا الشكل وهذه
الجراه لتستهدف الداخل التركي بالامس
وتقتل مدنيين بينهم طفل في مدرسته لذلك
انا اظن تركي لن يتوقف طيب لم يتوقف ولكن
هل لك ان تعطينا
عن طبيعه التحالفات الموجوده لانه يبدو
انها متشابكه اصدقاء على ارض واعداء في
ساحه ميدانيه اخرى وهنا اتحدث عن تركيا
همم الولايات المتحده وروسيا وانعكاسها
ايضا على ما يحدث في اوكرانيا لانه تركيا
وسيط هلا
صحيح صحيح يعني هذه نقطه مهمه تشرين اليها
نقطه اساسيه في تنسيق تركيا روسيا متزايد
في العوامل الاخيره سواء كان في الاسيت
انا وفي سوشي ومرتبط مباشره بالملف السوري
انه في تعداد روسيه قدمت همم لها همم
باتجاه ابعاد هذه المجموعات الى الداخل
السوري بعيدا عن الحدود وهذه وهذا التعهد
لم يتم التزامه هذه نقطه اولى اذا علمت
قبل ان تطالب انقرا في وقفه عمليتها
العسكريه انتاج هذا الحديث يطول الدكتور
سمير صالح اعذرني المتحده الامريكيه استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه لكن مضطره ان انهي
اللقاء لانه سننتقل مباشره الى الخرطوم
وهذه الكلمه لرئيس مجلس السياده السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان الى هناك اعتذر
[موسيقى]
منكراتيه الى مسارها الطبيعي والنوع
الاستعداد الى التام
للعب للعب ادوار ايجابيه في هذه القضيه
نسمي ايضا الجهود المبذوله لتحقيق الامن
والسلم في شرق دوله الكونغو
وانما على استعداد ايضا للمساهمه بايجابيه
في
احتواء هذه النزاعات الجيوب الكرام اننا
على قناعه تامه موسيقى وايمان
لجنه التنسيق الاقليميه
والياتها المتمثله في مركز الدمى
الاستقبال المشترك
ولما لديها من
امكافحه الظواهر السالبه المتمثله في
الحركات الضاره والقوه المسلحه والارهاب
والتطرف والالتزام
وجرائم العابره وجرائم المعلوماتيه
والتغلب على كافه التحديات الامنيه في
الاقليم وذلك من خلال التعاون والتنسيق
وتعزيز العلاقات بين اجهزه الامن
والمخابرات في هذا الاقليم الوعد اليوم
الكرام كتاما متجدد سعادتنا بوجودكم معنا
ونتمنى لكم اقامه طيبه ونامل ان تتكامل
مساعيكم وتكلف في هذا الاجتماع بالنجاح
والتوفيق والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
ايه ده المشاهدين استماعنا الى جزء من هذه
الكلمه طبعا من الخرطوم في المؤتمر السابع
عشر للجنه التنسيق الاقليميه عبد الفتاح
البرهان اكد فيما يتعلق بالسودان والداخل
السوداني ان المؤسسه العسكريه بنفسها كما
وعدت عن العمل السياسي على كل ننتقل الان
من السودان الى العراق من المقرر ان يناقش
البرلمان هناك اليوم ملف حفظ سياده البلاد
بعد سلسله الهجمات الايرانيه وايضا
التركيه المتكرره على اقليم كردستان
العراق البرلمان الاتحاد في بيان له وقال
ان جدول اعماله لجلسه اليوم سيقتصر على
موضوع حفظ سياده العراق وان الجلسه ستكون
مغلقه هذا وقد اعلنت رئاسه اقليم كردستان
العراق ان نجربان بارزاني سيتوجه الى
بغداد اليوم وذلك لعقد اجتماعات مع كبار
المسؤولين وايضا القوه السياسيه لبحث هذه
الهجمات الايرانيه التركيه الاخيره في
شمال البلاد كانت القوى الكردست داخل
البرلمان العراقي طلبه الحكومه باتخاذ
موقف قوي للرد على انتهاك السياده
العراقيه من المقرر اي يعقد البرلمان هذه
الجلسه اليوم طبعا للتركيز على هذه
المطالب تحديدا والمزيد معنى من بغداد
مراسل العربيه منتظر الرشيد اسمحلي ان
ابدا
بنجربان برزاني وهذه الزياره الى بغداد ما
الذي يحمله مع
يعني
في بغداد على راس هذه الملفات اولا ملف
الامن وتحديدا الغارات التركيه والايرانيه
المتكرره همم اضافه الى ذلك طبعا ملف
الموازنه وهناك ايضا مساله اخرى همم ربما
تتم مناقشتها وهي همم السبل الكفيله
بايقاف الغارات التركيه الايرانيه مع
بغداد للتنسيق طبعا في هذا الملف هناك عده
مطالب طبعا سواء للاتراك او حتى
للايرانيين بضروره انتشار قوات عراقيه
لحمايه الحدود العراقيه من عمليات التسلل
كما تقول طبعا تركيا وايران
للمعارضين للحكومهتين هنا الكوملاء همم
وايضا احزاب اخرى كرديه تتحرك على جانبي
الحدود هذا ما تقوله طبعا ايران وبالتالي
ايضا تركيا مشكلتها طبعا مع حزب العمال
الذي يتخذ من جبال القنديل
المدن في اقليم كردستان ايضا مقرات له
سنتحدث عن قضيه انتشار الجيش ولماذا هناك
فراغ بهذا الاطار ولكن اسمح لي ان اتحدث
عن ما يحدث اليوم في انتقادات خاصه
للحكومه العراقيه الموقف مما يحدث من
انتهاكات اعتبر خجول هل هذا بالفعل هذا
توجه الحكومه ام ماذا وماذا ننتظر من
اجتماع اليوم في البرلمان
وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه من عبرت على
الموقف الرسمي بحسب السياقات الرسميه كما
طبعا حاولنا معرفه موقف الحكومه اكثر من
مسؤول في هذه الحكومه اكد بان الخارجيه هي
من عبرت موقف هذه الحكومه من خلال بيانها
الذي استنكر طبعا الغارات الايرانيه على
الاراضي العراقيه ورفض العراق رفضا قاطعا
طبعا كما ورد في بيان الخارجيه مثل هذه
الغرارات اضافه الى همم ذلك
مواقف ربما ستتخذ طبعا داخل البرلمان
العراقي وان كانت الجلسه طبعا مغلقه ولم
تعقد حتى هذه اللحظه لكن ينتظر ان تعقد
خلال ربما دقائق او خلال اقل من ساعه هذه
الجلسه يتوقع ان يتم فيها اتخاذ قرار ما
بتكليف لجنه طبعا
لمتابعه همم تداعيات هذا القصف الايراني
وايضا البحث عن حلول لكن على ما يبدو هناك
خلافات ايضا داخل البرلمان الكتل الشيعيه
بغالبيتها طبعا ترفض صدور اي بيانات او
اتخاذ قرارات همم اكثر همم تقدما طبعا من
قرار الخارجيه العراقيه تجاه ايران اضافه
الى قوى اخرى طبعا كرديه تطالب حتى
باستضافه رئيس الحكومه همم على خلفيه
عمليات القصف الايرانيه وحتى التركيه لكن
لا يبدو ان البرلمان سيد يتفق طبعا على
قرار همم رابعا طبعا لوقف مثل هذه
العمليات سواء عمليات القصف الايرانيه او
حتى التركيه لمناطق اقليم كردستان مراسل
العربيه
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل في موقع
فورد النووي ايران تبدا تخصيب اليورانيوم
الى درجه نقاء 60 بالمئه تابعونا
اهلا بكم مجددا المشاهدين الى اخبار
الظهيره ونكمل هذه النشره من ايران وسائل
الاعلام ايرانيه قالت ان طهران بدات في
تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه 60 بالمئه بمنشاه
في الاردن نوويه رويترز نقلت عن تقارير
ايرانيه انا طهران تستخدم اجهزه طرد
المركزي متطوره من طراز اي ار 6 في منشات
بوردو واضافت ان ايران ستبني ايضا مجموعه
جديده من اجهزه الطرد المركزي في الموقع
وبهذا الاطار شدد مستشار الامن القومي
خلال لقاء مع رئيس هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيلي الجنرال ابيب كوخافي شدد على
دعم الاداره الامريكيه صارم للامن اسرائيل
بيان لمجلس الامن القومي اشاره الالتزام
الرئيس الامريكي جو بيضا شخصيا بضماني عدم
حصول ايران على السلاح النوويه كما اكد
الجانبان عزمهما المشترك على معالجه
التحديات الامنيه التي تؤثر على الشرق
الاوسط بما في ذلك التهديدات التي تشكلها
ايران
وكلاءها على كل مشاهدين تابع التطورات من
الداخل الايراني القضاء الايراني يتحدث عن
40 شخص من جنسيات اجنبيه اعتقلوا خلال هذه
الاحتجاجات طبعا بالفتره الاخيره كان في
تصريحات من الجانب الفرنسي تطالب فيها
فرنسا
بان يتم استرجاع مواطنين لها تقول بانهم
ليسوا من المخابرات كما تتهممهم همم ايران
طبعا وهنا نشاهد ان العدد يتوسع ولا نتحدث
فقط عن فرنسا لا نتحدث ايضا عن بريطانيا
لديها من المحتجزين البريطانيين ايضا في
السجون الايرانيه ولكن عن اكثر من جنسيه
غربيه تقول ايران بانها محتجزه وصل العدد
الى 40 نوافيكم بالمزيد حاله وروده ونعود
للحديث عن التطورات في الداخل الايراني
قائد قوى الامن الداخلي اعلن في محافظه
سيستان جنوب شرقي ايران محمد قنبري اعلن
عن مقتل شرطي وذلك في اطلاق نار داخل
مدينه زهدان وكاله اننا
قد نقلت عنها عن قمبر قوله ان مجموعه من
المستحل- المسلحين عذرا يستقلون سياره
اطلق النار باتجاه دوريه شرطه في زهدان
واضاف ان المسلحين لاذوا بالفرار فورا
تنفيذ الهجوم والذي اسفل ايضا عن اصابته
ضابط
وفي ردود الفعل حول ما يدخل يحدث في
الداخل الايراني قال رئيس المخابرات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه قال ان الاحتجاجات
التي تهز ايران بدات تشبه انتفاضه شعبيه
لكنه لا يرى اي خطر حقيقي بحسب تصريحه على
بقاء النظام في الوقت الحالي
الى انتفاضه الشعبيه عندما تنظر الى بعض
الحوادث والاضرار التي لحقت بالمؤسسات
الوطنيه ورموز الدوله وعدد القتلى هناك
شيء مختلف يحدث هنا يزعج النظام بشكل كبير
وبالتاكيد العقوبات والوضع الاقتصاديه حيث
ان العالم ليس في وضع الاقتصاد جيد عندما
تنظر الى الحاله الاقتصاديه الايرانيه
ومكان يجري على الارض في الشهرين الماضيين
او اكثر فان النظام منزعج حقا من احتمال
استمرار ذلك
لا ارى خطرا حقيقيا على دماغه ايه طب
اتصلك للكليين
الان مشاهدينا الى الملف الاوكراني
السفاره الروسيه في واشنطن اتهمت الولايات
المتحده بالتستر بحسب تصريحها على ما قالت
بانها جرائم ارتكبها الجيش الاوكراني وذلك
بحسب بيان السفاره البيان ذكر انه وبينما
لا يعامل ولا يعامل الجيش الاوكراني
الاسرى وفقا لاتفاقيه جنيف تتجنب واشنطن
والدول الغربيه انتقاد السلطات الاوكرانيه
السفاره الروسيه اشارت الى ان الولايات
المتحده تحولت الى طرف في النزاع وتدفع
العلاقات الى طريق مسدود طبعا في المقابل
حضر رئيس الاوكرانيفا الدول الاعضاء بحلف
شمال الاطلسي على ضمان حمايه المحطات
النوويه الاوكرانيه فيما اكدت الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اكدت ان اوكرانيا
نجد من كارثه خلال قتال وقع في مطلع
الاسبوع عند اكبر محطه للطاقه النوويه في
اوروبا
غور في سيبوني لقد تحدثت اليوم مع رئيس
الفرنسي من وين ماكرون حول تنفيذ عده نقاط
تتعلق بالسلامه الاشعاعيه والوضع في محطه
الطاقه النوويه في زامبوريجيا فضلا عن امن
الطاقه في اوكرانيا واوروبا نحن نعمل على
ضمان تنفيذ توجيهات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بوقف اي نشاط غذائي ضد
الاماكن النوويه الاوكرانيه ولهذا فان نزع
السلاح من محطه
الاهميه يجب على روسيا سحبه مقاتلها من
هناك ووقف قصفها لمحطه توليد الطاقه اشكر
الرئيس ماكرون على استعداده لدعمه حمايه
المنشات النوويه كما اننا نبذل قصار جهدنا
لعقد مؤتمر حول اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
حيث ابدى فرنسا استعدادها لاظهار زمام
المبادره بشكل مؤثر وفعال
طبعا مشاهدينا حديث زنسكي الان حول اعاده
الاعمار طبعا ترافقها بعض التصريحات
الاخرى ولكن اولا دعونا ننتقل الى هذه
الصور المباشره من تدفق الجماهير السعوديه
نحو الاستاذ بالعاصمه القطريه الدوحه طبعا
هذا الحضور هو
لموازره ومؤازره المنتخب السعودي الاخضر
امام الارجنتين اذن المشاهدين صور مباشره
لتوجه الجمهور الداعم للمنتخب السعودي
الاخضر امام الارجنتين اليوم في مباراه
اليوم بعد حوالي ربع ساعتين من الان
اذن مشاهدينا نتابع الان هذه الصور
المباشره من تدفق الجماهير السعوديه نحو
الاستاذ بالعاصمه القطريه الدوحه لمؤازره
المنتخب السعودي الاخضر امام الارجنتين
طبعا المشاهدين ان نعود الى تصريحات التي
اشار فيها الى عمليه اعاده الاعمار هذه
التصريحات تتزامن مع استعاده اوكرانيا
السيطره الكامله على خرسون بجنوب البلاد
انتصارات اوكرانيا تفتح الباب على
سيناريون فيلات المواجهه التفاصيل في هذا
التقرير
سلسله انتصارات اوكرانيا قد تتجه الى نقطه
انعطاف اخرى
فبالرغم من استعادتها مدينه خيرس بالكامل
بعد قتال عنيف الا انها قد تضع نفسها في
مرمى النيران بسبب تعريض امدادات القرم
للخطر وفقا للمعلومات التي ذكرتها جورنال
كما ان القوات الروسيه سحبت ما يصل الى
20,000 فردي من قوات النخبه بامان في خطوه
منها لاعاده الانتشار ونقلها الى جهه اخرى
بالقرب من مدينه خرسون للتحضر لمعركه اخرى
وفي المقابل العسكريون الاوكرانيون يرون
ان المعركه الصعبه ستكون خارج صفاته وهي
مدينه على اطراف سرسون والتي توجد فيها
نخبه من القوات الخاصه الروسيه تختلط
بالقوات التي تم تعبئتها حديثا بحسب
واشنطن بوست كما ان هؤلاء الجنود تدعمهم
طائرات استطلاع بدون طيار الاستهداف
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تحاول التقدم
زياده اعداد القوات الروسيه في خرسون
جنوبا ودوم باز شرقا قد يحد من قدرتها على
الهجوم في مواقع اخرى
كما ان هذا التقدم الاخيره للقوات
الاوكرانيه قد يمكنها من استهداف خطوط
الامداد الروسيه التي تصل الى شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا في عام 2014 خطوط
الامداد هذه تشكل اهميه قصوى لروسيا
خصوصا وان قواعدها العسكريه في شبه جزيره
القرم يعتمدون على الامدادات والمياه
العذبه من البر الرئيس الاوكراني التي تمر
عبر الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها الان
وبسبب هذه الاهميه قامت روسيا بالاستعداد
مسبقا في حاله حدوث في اي اختراق من
القوات الاوكرانيه
وذلك من خلال حفل خنادق بالقرب من حدود
شبه جزيره القرمودومباس اي على بعد 40
ميلا تقريبا خلف الخطوط الاماميه بحسب
تقرير نشرته وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
لصحيفه جورنال بالاضافه الى هذا الموقع
المهم الذي تستهدفه القوات الاوكرانيه
فهناك الجسر البري الذي يمتد غربا من
روسيا الى دينمو والذي تحاول كيف من خلاله
قطعه هذا الرابط الروسي الحيوي من خلال
التركيز على فك الحصار عن زموريج المحاصره
التي من شانها ان تقطع السبل بالقوات
الروسيه الى الغرب
وتعزل القوات في شبه جزيره القرم سلطان
العربيه
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل وزير
الدفاع الصيني يؤكد مجددا للنظيره
الامريكي ان تايوان خط احمر
[موسيقى]
واشنطن تعارض العمليات العسكريه التركيه
في سوريا والعراق وموسكو تدعو انقره الى
ضبط النفس
ايران تستخدم اجهزه طردا مركزي متطوره في
مفاعل فوردو وتسعه لتخصيب اليورانيوم
بنسبه 60%
وزير الدفاع الصيني يؤكد لنظيره الامريكي
ضروره احترام مصالح بلاده ويجددوا ان
تايوان خط احمر
ونائبه الرئيس الامريكي تعلن دعمها
للفلبين في مواجهه السياسات العدائيه ببحر
الصين الجنوبيه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره حضر
وزير الدفاع الصيني ويفينج حضر نظيره
الامريكيه لويد اوستن من ان قضيه تايوان
خط احمر ويجب عدم تجاوزه فالقضيه بحسب
الوزير الصيني تقع في قلب المصالح
الاساسيه للصين بحسب بيان لوزاره الدفاع
السنيه فقد دعى الوزير الصينيه نظيره
الامريكيه الى تبني سياسه منطقيه وعمليه
بحسب وصفه تجاهها الصين لاعاده العلاقات
الى المسار الصحيح شدد وزير الدفاع الصني
على ان حل قضيه تايون مساله تخص الشعب
الصيني وليس لاي قوه خارجيه الحق في
التدخل من جهه شدد اوستن على ان الولايات
المتحده ستستمر في الطيران والابحار
والعمل حيثما يسمح القانون الدولي بذلك
وائل العصفوره الازرق اعرض شركه الاتصالات
الفرنسيه
من عواقب الاقالات في شركه تويتر على
المستخدمين الشركه طلبت في بيان لها طلبه
تويتر بضمان التزاماته القانونيه بحلول
الرابع والعشرين من نوفمبر الجاري كما
طالبت شركه الاتصالات الفرنسيه تويتر
طلبتها ضروره التاكيد الالتزامه بضمانه
شفافيه المعلومات
وبيكافحه خطاب الكراهيه والتلاعب على
الرغم من سلسله التخفيضات الجذريه في
الوظائف على كل المزيد حول التطورات معنا
من سان فرانسيسكو مراسل العربيه
تحيه لك ميسون اليوم وخلال تواجد امام مقر
تويتر في سان فرانسيسكو كنت انتظر ان
اقابل عددا من الموظفين وكنت كلما يخرج
احد من
الشركه اساله اذا كان موظفا بشكل عام
جميعهم رفضوا ان يتحدثوا معي خاصه عندما
يعلمون اننا من الصحافه ورفضتنا الحديث مع
باقي وسائل الاعلام الموجوده التي كانت في
عين المكان ولكن المفارقه انني التقيته في
بشاب خرج من الشركه سالته هل هو همم موظف
لديها اجابني لا انا اتيته الى هنا لكي
يقدم سيرتي الذاتيه همم تعشيت فسالته همم
تقدم الذاتيه وهم الان يعني يفصلون الناس
قال بالعكس استقبلوني عندما قلت لهم اريد
ان اتقدم لوظيفه استقبلوه وهمم يعني سمحوا
له بالصعود الى مكاتب الشركه حيث قدم همم
سيرته الذاتيه همم طبعا في بعد ذلك تجولت
ايضا في اماكن
والمقاهي والمطاعم حيث كان يتواجد همم
العاملون والموظفون تويتر سالت العاملين
بهذه الاماكن هل لاحظوا همم غياب وجوه كان
يعرفونها او ان الاعداد همم قلت قالوا لي
بالفعل همم الاماكن لم تعد مزدحمه كما
كانت من قبل خاصه منذ ان اشتري الون ماسك
همم شركه التويتر فاذا همم هناك همم يعني
قله بالموجودين هناك تراجع بعد عدد
الذبائن لهذه الاماكن ما يدل على ان همم
الحجم كبير جدا من الموظفين الذين استغلوا
واشارنا اليه سابقا انه 1,100
استقاله يوم الخميس
هناك واليوم ايضا تم اقاله حسب الاعلام
الامريكي موظفين من قسم التوثيق عفوا
التسويق والمبيعات العربيه
من نوعها بين الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي ونظيره التركيه رجب طيب اردوغان
على هامش طبعا افتتاح بطوله كاس العالم
التي
تستضيفها قطر باب التساؤلات عن مستقبل هذه
العلاقه بين القاهره وطبعا مصر المتابعه
هذه القبضه التي تشد على يد الرئيس المصري
هي ذاتها التي كانت تلوح بالاصابع الاربعه
اشاره جماعه الاخوان المسلمين المحظوره
مياه كثيره جرت في النهر منذ ذلك الحين او
بالاحرف البحر وتحديدا شرق المتوسط حيث
ثروات الغاز ومطاميع تركيا
طلبوا انقر الوحيد من مصر وتغيير اسلوبها
تجاه وضع تركيا في البحر المتوسط طلب
بسيطا لكنه يوضح ماذا ياتي تركيا من
الحصول على موطئ قدم في عمليه استكشاف
الغاز في المتوسط بسبب تحالفات التي
تقيمها مصر خاصه مع كل من اليونان وقبرص
وتحقيقه هذا المسعى استخدم اردوغان طرقا
عده للضغط سواء بالتلوين بورقه الاخوان او
بتعزيز وجود بلاده العسكري في ليبيا على
بعد كيلومترات قليله من حدود مصر الغربيه
اما القاهره فلديها سلسله من المطالب
تتوقع ان تستجيب تركيا لها اذا كانت انقر
راغبه بالفعل في تطبيع العلاقات تم
التوافق على ان تكون المصاطحه بين
الرئيسين بدايه لتطوير العلاقات الثنائيه
بين الجانبين قائمه المطالب المصريه من
تركيا تتعدد لتشمل كبحه جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ومنعها من القيام بالتحريض
الاعلامي ضد الدوله المصريه
وتسليم عدد من الاخوان المطلوبين في قضايا
امنيه وسحب المرتزقه من ليبيا وانسحاب
القوات التركيه من هناك محاولات التقارب
بين مصر وتركيا ليست الاولى بل سبقتها
محاولات اخرى على مستويات اقل وكانت كلها
تبوء بالفشل
هذه هي المره الاولى التي يحدث فيها لقاء
على اعلى المستويات بين البلدين وهو ما
يفتح باب الامل لتحقيق اختراقه حقيقيه
تجاه تطبيع العلاقات
الى فاطمه واخبار الظهيره الاقتصاديه اليك
فاطمه
على اخر اخبار التي تحرك الاسواق في
المنطقه وايضا عالميا اعيننا تبقى على
اسعار النفط خلال الجلسه الان الاسعار
تعزز من الارباح تسجل ارتفاعات بحدود
الواحد في المئه بعض الجلسه التي شهدناها
يوم امس التي راينا فيها خسائر قويه
جعلتنا نتحدث انه براندي يتداول عند 82
دولار 31 سم لماذا تقارير هو استجابه ضغطت
على تداولات كانت تقول ان هناك مناقشات ما
بين اعضاء
لرفع الانتاج في اجتماع القادم بدايه
من قبل وزير الطاقه السعودي وزير الطاقه
الاماراتي وقبل قليل وزير الطاقه الكويتيه
ايضا ينسي مناقشه رفع الانتاج خلال
الاجتماع القادم من جهته يتحدث ربما عن
امكانيه المزيد من الخفض في الانتاج نحن
نعلم انه تخفيض الموافقه عليه بالاجتماع
السابق كلاس حدود اثنين مليون برميل كثير
من التقارير راجعت ارقام نمو الاقتصاد
العالمي نزولا رجعت ايضا ارقام الطلب على
النفط نزولا اوبك بلس تقريراتها او تقرير
بلوس للمره الخامسه بيراجعوا ارقام الطلب
نزولا خصوصا ونحن نقترب من عام 20 23
بالاضافه الى الوضع في الصين الوضع في
الصين غير مطمئن كنا راينا الفراجه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه بعد ما بدات الصين تفتح
ابوابها وتقلص من عمليه الاغلاق فدل
استمرارها بتطبيق استراتيجيه صفر كوبيد
اليوم همم الصين صباح هذا اليوم بيجين وكل
ما يجري هناك طغى على تداولات الاسواق
العالميه الاسواق الاسهم مع عوده اغلاق
مدن همم الصناعيه همم استراتيجيه بالطابعه
تلعب دور رئيسي في سلاسل الامداد العالميه
راينا اغلاقات متباينه في اسواق السياده
فلسف كلوز على اسواق اليابان ولكن راجع
بواحد فيلم اخر فاضل خسائر كانت بحدود 2%
الصين ايضا لا زالت مستمره بضخ السيوله في
القطاع العقاري بشكل رئيسي هذا بالنسبه
لاسواق اسيا اسواق المنطقه همم او الاسواق
الاوروبيه ايضا تبدا الجلسه على بعض
تراجعات الفيوتشر على تشير الى تراجعات
موضوع ستاندغت وموضوع رفع الفدرالي
الفائده في انتظار محضر الفيلمسي اجتماع
السابق مع انه بعض الاعضاء بدات تلمح انه
يمكن يكون في رفع الهاء ولكن بنسب اقل مما
رايناه في الاجتماعات السابقه وهذا ايضا
يجعلنا نتحدث عن تماسك في الدولار مقابل
سله من العملات استنيني همم يا ترى يرتفع
بشكل خفيف واسواق المنطقه معظمها باللون
الاحمر خسائر الاكبر على البورصه القتاليه
السعوديه ايضا تتراجع تصحيح للجلسه
الرابعه على التوالي دبي وابو ظبي نفس
القصه خسائر بحدود نصف نقطه مئويه اذا ان
نعود ببرامج اسواق العربيه ما الان عوده
اليك ميسي
حملي التدفق الكبير كما نشاهد من خلال هذه
الصور للجماهير السعوديه نحو استاد لوسيل
طبعا الكل هناك بالعاصمه القطريه الدوحه
لمؤازره المنتخب السعودي الاخضر امام
الارجنتين دعونا نشاهد هذه الصور ونستمع
اليها
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
من امام الاستاد معنى موفد العربيه فهد
الشهري اللي ينقل لنا الاجواء من هناك فهد
تفضل
نعم ميسون لاجواء جميله جدا اجواء منذليات
تدفق الجمهور من قبل اربع ساعات من
الثامنه صباحا للملعب حيث فتحت الابواب في
الساعه 9:00 حضور جمهور كبير اعتقد ان
الملعب الجميل ملعب لوسيل اللي خلفنا راح
يكون ممتلئ بالكامل من الجماهير السعوديه
وايضا الجماهير الارجنتينيه
نعم ااا عصام هذا حضور الجمهور الجمهور زي
ما تشوفين لازال يحضر ملعب
في اجواء الجماهريه تشاهد الرقصات
المختلفه تشاهد التحديات شاهد الى الجمهور
اللي يحمل كاس العالم شاهد الجمهور اللي
يحمل نجوم المختلفه في المنتخبين اللي
يحمل الارجنتين اللي يحمل صوره ليونيل
ميسي السعودي اللي يحمل صوره سالم الدوسري
تبادل التحديات تبادل
الجميله اللي راح ايضا يحتضن ايضا نهائي
كاس العالم في قطر 2002 وعشرين الجمهور
السعوديه حضر ومكه المتفائل بمنتخبه يثق
في ان شاء الله انه يقدم مستوى
مرشح منتخب قوي زي المنتخب الارجنتيني ما
يسوى طيب على كلن يبدا ان هناك تقطع
بالصوت خلينا نركز الصوره حتى يثبت الصوت
فهد باختصار تشكيله المنتخب الاخضر خبرنا
نعم عصام عصام تشكيله المنتخب الاخضر نزلت
قبل الوقت قليل كانت نفس التشكيله اللي
خاضها السيد هرفي رونالد في الرياض امام
المنتخب الكرواتي مع تغيير في قلب الدفاع
حسان تمبكتي بديلا الى العامري بجانب وهمم
علي البليهي بالاطراف سعود عبد الحميد
وياسر الشهراني
عبد الله المالكي محمد كانه في خط الوسط
سلمان الفرج في راس البركان وسالم الدوسري
وفي الامام المهاجم صالح الشهري تشكيله
المنتخب جديده تشكيله ما خاف فيها اي
مباراه
في المباريات الوديه نتمنى انه تحقيق
المطلوب طبعا فهد السؤال الاخير باختصار
الحضور الرسمي
[موسيقى]
الحضور الجماهيري نعم يحدد ويقدر بعدد
15000 مشجع سعودي البقيه كلهم يا مستمتعين
يا ايضا جمهور الارجنتيني كبير جدا
في هذه المباراه ميسون نبغى ناخذ بس رايي
شويه للمشجعين السعوديين قبل المباراه
ممكن دقيقه حياك الله
المباراه خلاص على الابواب عطني شعورك
والله نتمنى ان يقدم المنتخب الاداه اللي
همم يتامل كل الجمهور
الاكثر في مباراه مثلا زي الارجنتين
الافضل انك همم اقلها الاداء افضل من اكثر
من النتيجه لان همم باذن الله يعني
المجموعه في امل انا باذن
[موسيقى]
حياك الله الله يحييك مرتبك والله ناوي في
خوف في خوف قدام تلعب قدام الارجنتين قدام
ميسي افضل لاعب في العالم طبيعي الخوف لكن
ان شاء الله نقول اول نص ساعه اذا مرت
بالتعادل نقول ان شاء الله نقدر في
المباراه نقدر باذن الله
في المنتخب السعودي
اثرا اندلاع حريق ضخم في مصنع في مدينه
الصينيه اكدت وسائل الاعلام محليه ان فرق
الاطفاء ارسلت اكثر من ثلاث و60 مركبه الى
مكان الحادث تمكنت من السيطره على الحريق
خلال ثلاث ساعات تقريبا علما بان شخصين لا
يزلان في اعداد المفقودين وفق المصادر
نفسها
تشد مبيعات البيض المكون الاساسي في وجبه
الفطور الانجليزيه ازمه في بريطانيا
بريطانيا عذرا تقرير مراسله العربيه عروه
عبد الحق من لندن
تكاد لا تخلو وجبه الفطور الانجليزيه من
البيض المكون الاساسي الذي اشتهرت به وجبه
الانجلش ليس فقط في بريطانيا وانما في
العالم لكن الوجبه الانجليزيه باتت هي
الاخرى مهدده مضيفه ازمه اخرى الى ملف
الازمات التي تمر بها بريطانيا فالى جانب
ارتفاع تكلفه الانتاج الناتج عن الوضع
الاقتصادي المتازم اساسا جاء انتشار
انفلونزا الطيور في المزارع البريطانيه
ليزيد المشكله حيث باتت رفوف البيض في
المتاجر شبه خاليه بعد اضطرار العديد من
اصحاب مزارع الدواجن الى اعدام الدجاج
المريض
كميات للتاكد من انه في المتاجر لا يستطيع
المطعم محلي ان يشتري خمسه او عشره علب
بيض مره واحده لان ذلك سيعني ان زبائن
المحل المحليين لن يحصلوا على البيض
لانفسهم
ومع تحضيرات من نقص كبير في مخزون البيض
بحلول عيد الميلاد بدات متاجر بريطانيه
مثل لذل واعزى بتقنين شراء البيض مع توجه
العديد من المتاجر الاكبر مثل تاكو وغيرها
الى اتخاذ اجراءات مماثله
البريطانيون من جانبهم لاحظوا نقص في
البيض حيث انتشر هاشتاج النقص في البيض
على منصه التواصل الاجتماعي
بيضه واذا تم الحد من ذلك فسيكون ذلك
تحديا
الينا الناس في الريف لديهم الدجاج الخاص
بهم هناك اشياء اخرى لاكلها ولن اتاثر
كثيرا
تقول النصيحه عاده لا تضع كل البيض في سله
واحده لكن مع النقص في مخزون البيض
وارتفاع تكلفه رعايه الدواجن قد يصبح من
الحكمه ان تضع ما يتاح لك من البيض في
سلتك الشرائيه قبل ان يصبح شراء البيض
ترفا او خيارا غير متاح
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
العسكريه التركيه في سوريا والعراق وموسكو
تدعو انقره الى ضبط النفس
ايران تستخدم اجهزه طرد مركزي متطوره في
مفاعل فورد وتسعه لتخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
60%
وزير الدفاع الصيني يؤكد لنظيره الامريكي
ضروره احترام مصالح بلاده ويجددوا
النتايوان خط احمر
ونائبه الرئيس الامريكي تعلن دعمها
للفلبين في مواجهه السياسات العاديه ببحر
الصين الجنوبيه
وصلنا الى نهايه اخبار الظهيره نلتقي غدا
ونشره جديده
[موسيقى]